this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
so we'll continue our talk here of
secondary structure by talking about the
other ordered pattern of the backbone of
the polypeptide chain we've already
talked about fit Hillis ease so now in
this video we're gonna talk about beta
pleated sheets ok so beta pleated sheets
look a lot different than alpha helixes
what do they look like like this so when
it comes to the ribbon diagrams they're
represented by these arrows which appear
to be flat ok and specifically and
they're not quite actually flat I'll go
back to that momentarily but when it
comes to the arrows the base of the
arrow represents the amino end and the
tip of the arrow represents the carboxy
end and so these sheets have
directionality and when we have two
sheets basically running in the same
direction we consider them parallel and
of course if they're running in opposite
directions we would consider them anti
parallel and of course they're not
exactly flat that's they sort of up may
appear that way sort of as when you look
at them from a zoomed out perspective
but when you zoom in you can see that
the sheets are really made up of these
like peptide chains and of course they
have that sort of angled geometry right
hence the the police which make it look
sort of like that as opposed to a flat
structure now here we basically have two
beta sheets and they're both running
sort of in a horizontal fashion right we
can see that this sheet up top is
horizontal as is this one and I haven't
specified with these two sheets whether
they're parallel or antiparallel and I'm
not going to really discuss that here
but what's important eyes is that the
direction of the sheet each of these
sheets is horizontal and the hydrogen
bonds that hull are holding them
together are nearly perpendicular to the
directions of those sheets okay and we
could see those hydrogen bonds here here
and here
they're not exactly perpendicular but
they're nearly perpendicular to
direction of those sheets okay which is
worth noting
here's a quick 3d visual of some beta
pleated sheets in this protein here we
can see these strands here one going
down this way and this was went up this
other way so they're running anti
parallel to each other
so we're gonna take a little chunk out
of this protein and get rid of the rest
of it take a closer look at these
strands that make up this beta sheet so
we're specifically highlighting this
molecule and showing the hydrogen bonds
and maybe you can already see them
they're a little dotted green line we're
gonna zoom in a little closer in on them
and now we can see them here right these
hydrogen bonds are running perpendicular
to the direction of these strands that
make up this beta sheet right so see
them going there as I sort of follow
along that sheet they're running
perpendicular to the direction of these
peptide strands okay now there are some
things of course that can disrupt the
beta pleated sheets actually just one
thing and that's actually heat right and
why is that well heat disrupts hydrogen
bonds so the heat would be able to
disrupt these hydrogen bonds that hold
the different sheets together and and
denature them okay now that's of course
worth mentioning especially as it
relates to alpha Hillis these alpha
helixes have a lot more things that can
disrupt them and beta pleated sheets
really is just heat that can disrupt
them and beautifully these sheets are
are less susceptible to denaturation
because of this okay they're actually
far more stable than then alpha helixes
okay which is something that's worth
noting cool that's about it I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching